Amazon's planned acquisition of Whole
Foods highlights the explosive growth in
organic food sales the US Department of
Agriculture says that foods labeled
organic must be grown without synthetic
fertilizers and be free from genetically
modified organisms meats miss different
animals raised without antibiotics or
growth hormones and with access to the
outdoors
it stands say organic foods have greater
nutritional benefits and can even help
fight cancer that's why they sometimes
spend nearly twice as much for an
organic product compared to a
non-organic one but our organics really
healthier will they really worth the
money here's the situation concerns
about the growing use of pesticides and
use of antibiotics and animal feed
prompted some consumers to look for
so-called
organic food in 1990 Congress passed the
organic foods production Act to develop
national standards and organic products
became more common mainstream grocery
chains started their own lines of
organic food and larger food companies
began acquiring smaller health food
companies to get in on the action
now from the big boxes to the small
specialty stores three-quarters of US
grocers sell organic foods here's the
argument proponents say that organic
produce has more nutrients including
antioxidants and vitamins than
conventionally grown fruits and
vegetables they also suggest eating
organic limits exposure to toxic
chemicals that may lead to certain
cancers but while eating organic does
reduce your exposure to pesticides
there's no evidence that the trace
amounts and food are a danger scientific
surveys haven't found that organic foods
are much more nutritious and just
because food is organic it doesn't mean
that it's good for you it may be nearly
as high in sugar sodium and other
unhealthy ingredients as non organic
products yet more farms are going
organic feed the appetite for pure foods
pretty good with big supermarket chains
like Kroger selling more organic
products and Amazon's determination to
drive down prices at Whole Foods organic
foods should only increase in popularity
healthy or not
you